it's not tea what's up nobody how's it
going nobody know it's exciting to talk
to nobody right now apparently knowing
no one's been notified oh hey look Phil
drinks water there we go there's the
people piling on edge back in so we're
on the road to go to Monette Moyles
birthday party Lorna hasn't been on the
channel in forever but it's been a while
but we decided we're gonna go there say
happy birthday to her and we figure
since we're on the road we got like 15
minutes here we'll go say we'll go live
with you guys we'd like to take Sundays
off but we still do work on Sunday
there's a lot of emails and stuff whoa
hey Timmy
Terminator songs just uh just pledged
not pledged but son contributed tipped
$2 thanks buddy thank you thank you I'll
use that money to buy Monette a drink
tonight
I really appreciate it so much well guys
we only got like 10 to 15 minutes on the
road so get your questions in mouska get
whatever you want in right now did you
guys see the photos of the Martin
Scorsese he set for the Irishman they're
really filming it now man they're really
filming it I'm so excited to see that
movie Joe Pesci Pacino no in IRL so cool
so cool we're gonna terminate her songs
you must have missed it we're going to
Mona Mona Mona birthday party yeah I
have this flannel shirt because my
girlfriend likes flannel because she's
from Colorado and all those douchebags
were you're from Colorado you're wearing
a dear it's a douchey flannel shirt so I
was like yeah sure a five flannel shirt
if it makes me look more attractive in
your eyes
yeah who's all in here we're in
California guys we're in California
Kali's - Tim inator songs Tim and
nature's imitating sorry sorry
terminator a man is getting mad at me
right now yeah yeah I'm supposed to get
a right Greg I heard the last Justice
League trailer comes out before Blade
Runner we got this deal going to go
cover it's not solidified yet but we're
supposed to be couple days like a
haunted theater experience yeah I mean
it's like it's like this big new movie
theater that's doing a whole bunch of
special promotions and special like
events for Halloween yeah yeah yeah
every weekend don't have to a theater
decked out with you know decorations and
they'll have costumes around they've got
different like little experiences like
it sounds cool it sounds really cool and
it's kind of thrown off our schedule a
little bit we were gonna go watch Blade
Runner Thursday night but now it looks
like we're gonna go watch it Saturday
afternoon is that review Prague won't be
up till Sunday but we're headed for it
man we're in Los Angeles by the way
someone asked if we're gonna watch it
Justice League nah maybe maybe you know
I'm gonna protest that film cuz Joss
Whedon got a writing credit for it and
it's not all about that you know I'm
just not I'm not more about excited for
that I'm super excited for Blade Runner
man yeah definitely dude the Goss wing
and then the Ford Motor Company in one
movie together
that's exciting where are you even if
it's 818 a.m. over there hey do you guys
like riff do you guys actually like like
riff because we got a riff account and
we still haven't used it we're seeing
all these people using R if this is
actually gonna be worth it I want to do
it let's say you know if you live near
LA you got it let us know when you're
near LA you gotta come say hi to us now
we haven't seen Gerald's game yes we
were thinking of using riff to go watch
Gerald's game because we heard it's
pretty damn good a lot of amazing things
about Gerald's game didn't love that
trailer but oh dude Drago
I'm so excited for Infinity Ward I mean
we saw the trailer that premiere during
Jimmy Kimmel and the Inhumans yeah that
everyone was telling me about in common
boxes to go pay attention to look out
for it so I didn't go out Friday doesn't
wanted to make sure I was around for it
did you guys see it it was such a good
trail oh man all the Avengers
they're all they're all there than a
highest-performing video of the year
tell us what you guys thought of that
video that we put up that day easily
made 20 bucks I would never watch a
leaked video of that no we did not watch
Inhumans no no no no we did I heard is
the worst of the worst
what upcoming movie are you most excited
for I feel like if you guys are wanting
to hear an answer I would say the last
Jedi that's not my real answer I'm
really excited for the foreigner dude
two minutes of songs you know German and
another dollars who was geminated you
becoming my favorite one over here my
favorite one bunny just bought my love
permanently my girlfriend spoils me
that's the only thing that keeps this
relationship moving is the fact that she
cares for everything so this is my
present for Bonett
today every every one of my friends it's
a gets a dollar for their birthday and
it's been that way since I was a little
kid and had zero money that would
scratch up a dollar
of course John looks sexy everyone
always promised on John's lips no one
ever comments on my
you love our reaction videos do you
actually just only watch the reaction
part or do you watch all the commentary
parts you know because this is what we
like what people who watch those parts I
mean the reactions are good too but the
commentaries where we actually you know
get to justify our presence yeah yeah
dude 2 minute is good he's contributed
four dollars in total Terminator do two
more the whole inator I can get coffee
you got a sip sound that out Thank You
Jay for saying that looks sexy half dude
yeah I don't understand so much of these
internet lingo things AF means ass fun
yeah I know it means it's [ __ ] but
there's so many times where I'm like
what the hell does like what's the other
one I had I likes lose that the look up
what the hell these words mean like when
we go on down and they're like FTW yeah
I always thought they were saying like
[ __ ] these something w5o Naveen Naveen
you just see just contribute two dollars
right here okay I think I was talking to
me I'm pretty sure I might beginning his
name confused with someone who might
have a same exact name but he looks like
him I'm assuming it's you there's more
than one you might be on Indian friend
in New Jersey
thanks thanks debt den Rick
no okay is there a different Naveen how
are you
guys look LA this is Hollywood Boulevard
don't you guys want to see Hollywood
Boulevard look how sexy it is I did a
photo shoot in one of those rooms one
here's a traditional angry homeless man
passing by it looks no I saw him yelling
at someone on the corner always I need a
star stargazer
I think I need a reply to my last text
message I was asking her about coming
back on the channel I think she's busy
Wednesday I don't know I was helping a
friend move all day yesterday so I'm
like super behind on my text messages
dereck cannot believe I read his comment
it's really hard to read these comments
right now I'm keeping my battery low
because my phone's really low on battery
I'm getting my my and my screen low Tim
inators just trying to like he is slowly
winning my heart over more and more by
every dollar he pledges every five
minutes
hey John peach has a question for us do
we eat Taco Bell yeah I do sometimes
like once in a while when I haven't had
much to eat that day and it's like the
weekend it's late and I just want to
feel like I'm treating myself no joke
for about two years over John our talked
about the other day up until this year
when I started losing weight there's
about two years of the channel we're
like four to five days a week we would
leave at like 3:00 in the morning and
grab like a heavy ass fast food it's a
combination of Taco Bell jackin the-box
Burger King and McDonald's but then you
know Fridays were special that's when we
got Internet yeah are we more excited
for a Friday 13th reboot or Halloween
Halloween I am probably more excited for
the Halloween one I'm mostly worried
about Friday this one I need is a
universal right now I was watching she
is going to four nights couldn't make it
I couldn't make it this particular
Sunday but I'm happy she's going I gotta
get some Horror Nights tickets
peach wants to know if we still watched
Jeremy Jones now he really disrespected
me when we were at Collider I was gonna
put up a whole video about it but he was
a total dick just right now every week I
watched Jeremy Johnson even watching my
movie talk man
awesome tacular is mummy 2017 the worst
movie of the year no I'm not gonna tell
you guys what the worst movie is that I
saw this year
I'll tell you how we stick to our guns
though we got offered they were gonna
pay us to review a movie and they were
gonna pay us a pretty hefty amount so
we're like yeah let's check out your
movie
and then we saw the movie and we were
and we will not tell you what the movie
is out of respect for these people who
gave us the offer because that's the
part to do but they gave us an offer
that we were like that's a pretty big
lump sum of money right there and then
we watched the movie and it was easily
like I hated the movie just like I
couldn't stand it it was terrible and I
was like honestly guys as much as it
would be nice to receive a large amount
of money because I don't like the movie
I will not do this review because I just
don't want I don't like lying or being
like I don't like lying about what a
product is or whatever isn't especially
for a movie you just like this lot more
than I did I just saw it you know it's a
fine low budget it's just the same
low-budget kind of quality level so it's
like I can't recommend you in a way
that's like people gotta check out you
don't like a heavily advertised film or
something it's not like a shitty movie
but at the same time it's like I can't
give you what you want yeah oh we just
parked
okay that's cool let me see here hey
Seth
Seth's just pitched in five bucks you
tipped us five bucks
hey we got to answer this question from
Seth cuz he asked he just contributed
five bucks here you think two hours two
hours yeah I don't want beer that long
this is if you got a chance please watch
for me this squirrel on the ill will
press Channel I could die happy he
started watching this video a screen
shot can you remember that just in case
just in case they're cool when it comes
to new YouTube channels we like to get
permission in advance before hand it to
make sure we can do that repeat this
[ __ ] to me
I forgot let me see if I could pull it
back up here they will press channel
will fo me this squirrel never heard of
that
that sounds pretty funny yeah we should
get going inside because this thing
started at three oh dude it's already
four 2000 that means I'm hopefully
they're wrapping up III want to take
Sunday tonight to work on some writing
for my own thing
Tim minute sir thank you so you've
contributed like seven bucks or
something so far I really appreciate it
guys do you actually have like a song
channel or something anyway hey guys
thank you so much for everyone who's
been here for this random little
livestream we did we'd like to do these
on the road live saloon Seth thank you
so much for being here Tim minitor songs
naveen you guys are so awesome I really
appreciate everyone who's been here for
the channel we had a really fun month
doing YouTube for the month of September
October is gonna be a lot of horror
stuff I guarantee it somebody disaster
for PewDiePie man I don't think any
youtuber is a PewDiePie fan that's not
true alright guys we'll talk to you soon
much love